PARAGRAPH YOU CAN THINK OF.
THEY WILL BE HELL-BENT ON
PUSHING THIS AGENDA DOWN YOUR
THROAT.
HERE WITH MORE ON THE UPCOMING
MIDTERMS, LAST NIGHT'S BIG
WINNER OUT OF WYOMING, HARRIET
HAD MENACED WITH US.
CONGRATULATIONS, LOOKS LIKE ALL
OF THE POLLS WERE ACCURATE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK HAPPENED?
LOOK FOR EXAMPLE, I THOUGHT BACK
AND I DID NOT REMEMBER LIZ
CHENEY SPEAKING OUT TO WHEN
HILLARY CLINTON'S DIRTY DOSSIER
WAS BEING USED BY THE FBI AND
ABUSING POWER AND LYING BEFORE
FISA COURTS, WHY IS IT TO --
WHAT IS IT ABOUT DONALD TRUMP
THAT SEEMS TO TRIGGER HER MORE
THAN ANYTHING ELSE?
>> WELL, I AM NOT QUITE SURE,
SEAN, AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME ON THIS EVENING.
YESTERDAY WAS A GREAT DAY FOR
WYOMING AND REALLY A GREAT DAY
FOR THE COUNTRY.
I DON'T REALLY KNOW THAT IT CAN
GET INTO LIZ CHENEY'S MIND, NOR
DO I REALLY WANT TO.
BUT GUESS WHAT I WOULD SAY IS
THAT THE FOLKS OF WYOMING HAVE
SPOKEN AND THEY HAVE MADE IT
CLEAR THAT THEY BELIEVE THEY ARE
ENTITLED TO A REPRESENTATIVE IN
CONGRESS THAT REPRESENTS THEIR
INTERESTS AND DOES NOT INTEND TO
PURSUE A ONE-WOMAN WAR AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP.
WE DID NOT SEND HER TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., TO BE THE
JUDGE AND JURY OF DONALD TRUMP.
WE SENT HER TO WASHINGTON, D.C.,
TO BLOCK THE RADICAL BIDEN
AGENDA AND TO BLOCK THE RADICAL
PELOSI AGENDA AND SHE SIGNED ON
WITH BOTH OF THEM.
SO YESTERDAY WYOMING SPOKE AND
SAID, WE HAVE HAD ENOUGH, WE ARE
FED UP.
WE WILL TAKE OUR COUNTRY BACK.
WE ARE STARTING RIGHT HERE IN
WYOMING.
>> Sean: LET'S TALK ABOUT.
I WATCHED HER SPEECH LAST NIGHT.
I THINK SHE IS SINCERE IN HER
BELIEFS AND IS ALLOWED TO
BELIEVE ANYTHING THAT SHE WANTS,
PURSUE ANY AGENDA THAT SHE
WANTS, BUT CLEARLY AT SOME
POINT, SHE GOT OUT OF TOUCH WITH
THE PEOPLE OF WYOMING, WHICH IS
WHY YOU WON BY SUCH AN
OVERWHELMING MARGIN.
SHE MENTIONED THAT SHE CALLED
YOU.
I DID NOT HEAR IN THAT SENTENCE
THAT SHE CONGRATULATED YOU AND
WISH YOU WELL, HOW DID THE CALL
GO?
>> WELL, THERE WAS NOT A PHONE
CALL, WHILE I WAS GOING AND
GETTING READY TO DO MY
ACCEPTANCE SPEECH LAST NIGHT AND
JUST ARRIVED AT THE WATCH PARTY,
SHE CALLED AND LEFT A VERY BRIEF
TO SECOND MESSAGE ON MY
CELL PHONE.
THAT'S THE EXTENT OF IT.
I HAVE NOT HAD ANY OTHER CONTACT
WITH LIZ CHENEY PURGING ONLY
MADE ONE EFFORT AND ALL SHE SAID
WAS HELLO, HARRIET.
AND THEN THAT WAS THE END OF IT.
SO SHE DIDN'T CALL AND DISCUSS
WITH ME ANY KIND OF CONCESSION
OR ANYTHING ELSE.
IT WAS JUST THE ONE PHONE CALL.
I WAS OBVIOUSLY EXTREMELY BUSY
WITH FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
>> Sean: SHE JUST SAID HELLO,
HARRIET, AND THEN HUNG UP.
>> THAT WAS THE END OF THE CALL
COMING AT US, THE ONLY TIME.
IT WAS ABOUT 8:15 LAST NIGHT AND
I WAS GETTING READY TO GO ON
STAGE WITH MY ACCEPTANCE SPEECH
AND I DID NOT HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT WITH HER.
>> Sean: OKAY, WELL, WE ARE
LOOKING FOR, OBVIOUSLY I THINK
YOU ARE A LOCK TO WIN THE SEAT.
AT THE PEOPLE OF WYOMING SENT A
LOUD MESSAGE LAST NIGHT AND WE
WISH YOU A LOT OF LUCK, AND WHEN
YOU GO TO THAT SEWER AND SWAMP
IN WASHINGTON, PLEASE DON'T LET
IT CHANGE WHO YOU ARE.